Whenever we query the database, we get
a cursor back that contains columns.
Each column has an integer
index assigned to it.
Up until now,
we've had to call getColumnIndex for
each column in order to get this index.
But, there is a way to avoid doing that.
We can create a projection which is
just an array of the columns we want to
return in our cursor.
This is more efficient because we
are only fetching the data from
the database that we need to use and
since the database always returns
the columns in the order we specify,
we can rely on the indices matching
the order from our projection.
So we can then just use these indices
to get information from our cursor.
One minor note.
Since we are doing a join on our
weather with location queries,
we have to specify which ID we want
explicitly in our projection by adding
the table name followed by a dot before
the column name, as in this example.